[Music]
been a very rough week for republican
presidential candidate mitt romney his
campaign was rocked by the release of
those embarrassing quotes he made it a
private donor meeting and now president
obama is starting to open up a lead in
several key states
so now the republicans are really going
on the offensive they released a new
attack ad today and i looked at it
hasn't been it's just out there a few
hours ago i watched it i think it's a
bit of a stretch
with mitt romney falling in the polls
many are saying he's not fit to lead and
the only choice is barack obama there's
just one problem there is no barack
obama
that's right barack obama doesn't exist
ask yourself have you ever met barack
obama
shaking his hand or had a beer with him
no and why do you think that is
because he doesn't exist exactly
open change more like smoke and mirrors
why was his birth certificate so hard to
find
because he was never born
fact that election night speech in grant
park chicago was actually a staged
performance during a scent break of a
free green day concert
fact the people you've been seeing for
the past four years are actually trained
stage actors don jenkins jr felicia
bennett shirley ellis and kiara simpson
you may remember don jenkins jr from the
fall 1979 sears catalog
sure we all laughed at clint eastwood
talking to the empty chair but trust us
his obama was as real as any other
vote for the only actual candidate in
the race mitt romney
better than no one
[Applause]